-How are you?
-I'm just having
a relaxing bath.
That's it.
-Yeah, this film is about
a relaxing bath.
-It's just a cozy night in.
-This was a terrifying movie
for me to watch because --
Well, I guess we should explain
what's happening there.
Is your --
-I'm in labor.
-You're in labor.
-I'm not having a relaxing bath.
-Yeah, you're in labor.
-Attempting to give birth
silently.
-And you are giving birth
silently because the monsters
in this film are attracted
to sound.
-Yes, like acutely attracted.
-And my wife's about to have a
baby, and it was not a good time
to watch this movie.
-Listen, I did it silently.
She can do it.
-[ Laughing ] She can do it.
Although I guess the upside is
no matter how it goes,
at least there won't be a sound
monster in the delivery room.
-Apart from you screaming.
-That's true.
Which I did last time,
to a great effect.
-Oh, you did? Yeah.
-So, this is the first time
you and John
have worked together.
-Yeah!
-I'm assuming people have tried
to get you to do things
in the past.
-Well, they have,
but we've sort of been offered
every romantic comedy
under the sun.
But no one wants to see John
and I kind of meeting in a film.
Like, people wouldn't buy it.
Like, "Hey, I'm Meredith,"
and like, "Hey, I'm Paul."
You know, it's like --
it's never good.
-Yeah, that's true.
-'Cause that's how
all romantic comedies go, guys.
-Usually, there's always a Paul.
-There's, like, a template.
-Yeah.
But this horror film,
he directed, he co-wrote it.
-Yeah.
-And --
-He's a show-off.
-He's a show-off, he really is.
And he's wonderful in it.
-[ Indistinct ]
-Was this a case of him trying
to get you to do it, you trying
to get him to put you in it,
or did you immediately
both agree to it?
-You know, we've always
sort of been protective of
each other's projects.
And in this case,
he got sent the script and I had
just had our second child,
like, literally just had
our second child -- silently.
And --
[ Laughter ]
And I was about
to do Mary Poppins,
so I wasn't in the sort
of headspace of, like,
horrific horror movie.
But then he wrote it,
and then I read it
and I just loved it.
So this was the one.
I just thought the concept was
so ambitious, so unique.
It was sort of bigger than
the fact that we were
a married couple in a movie
together, you know.
-It's incredibly
tightly plotted.
-Yeah.
-It's a really efficient film
in that there's
this really great premise
and I feel like
it played out beautifully.
-Thank you.
-And terrifyingly.
I feel like it's so beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
But once you decided to do it,
was he all-in on the idea?
-Oh, he was so excited.
And I was awkward about it.
I was like, "Would you ever want
me to do this movie,
or would that be weird?
I mean, you don't have
to say yes, I don't know."
And he was really happy.
-Now, obviously he spent a lot
of time working on the script,
co-writing it.
Are you a good person
to bounce ideas off?
-I mean, I thought I was.
And then he informed me that I
had, like, a resting bitchface.
I wasn't aware that was a thing.
[ Laughter ]
I understand there's
a hashtag or something.
But yeah, I had heard it
from a couple of directors
that I'm very impassive
when you're pitching me an idea.
And his impersonation of me is
when he's enthusiastically
pitching me an idea,
that I just go like this.
[ Laughter ]
And not strangely quickly. Like,
sort of crunching the numbers
on whether I liked it or not.
-I shouldn't say
that is not an accurate reaction
to a single thing that happens
in this film.
There's not a single scare
where you're like, "Uh-huh."
-Like, "Okay, whatever," yeah.
-And then, is it weird --
I would imagine for
the birthing scene...
-Yeah.
-...like it must be very hard
for the man who is in the room
when you actually gave two
children to give you direction.
-Gave two children to him.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Does he just sort of let
you use your own instincts?
-Honestly, I think if he'd had
one note I would've been like,
"Shut up," right?
"You don't know."
So yeah, he kind of just let me
have a freewheeling experience
during that time.